welcome to this video I'm playing
international master for euro from
Argentina and benoni we we have making a
conscious effort to play quickly let's
see how this is going to end I have
provided the f3 f3 move for a while okay
so he is playing for a fire which is a
typical advanced here what I'm wondering
is should I play a three or should I
just yeah maybe i can i can go here not
sure about a three of course i need to
play the F porn at some point because my
night on HD is such a such a stupid
piece but i'm not sure if I maybe should
play maybe f4 here it's not bad there's
also bishop age 60 s like Bishop age 6
in the scandal position getting rid of
this bishop
if I if he allows me to exchange and
when I play a 4 then why does an
excellent shape this would be a sort of
automatic central attack so he needs to
yeah he needs to do something out of the
ordinary this is one of those yeah okay
yeah it looks really ridiculous I know
but I need to plan it to move the
airport okay so he allows me to do that
I find really strange or take first okay
yeah it's good for white anyway now I
just I just have a central dominance
here and its really doesn't matter what
is I mean white white is just just ready
but I am so he five instantly now come
on I can I have time I can play this
first the only thing could be Queen
deform yeah a case where you should have
thought just to just a second longer
okay I don't want to exchange Queens
YUM all right I take all these Tempe
don't don't mind if 593 is got Queen
default check
yeah this is also good
oh what a terrible game I mean I could
have just take any form could have just
taken you for very easily and now
everything so again all right for me
okay so a fraud I'm maintaining nida for
so he probably needs to play d five half
dozen be forgot that he for was saying
I find it very hard to believe that you
can take on a 59 f 436 how can you can
you ever check survive that
9f for again coming nidoqueen g 6 26 is
the the problem yeah I could have just
taken you forward first I will man ok so
let's see how to how to win the snow not
allow any any funny business
yeah I this chick first then now open up
Queen g3 h4 so one idea
Queen h4 looks really deadly now
I don't see a defense maybe ruka 42
delayed a bit but i will just win the
crew though kicking side and probably
made him check check yeah chanting wins
basically black resigns yeah this wasn't
too bad besides the fact that I just
blunder deform I could have just taken
you for 993 is just ridiculous you can
just take you forward I resign I
completely forgot forgot about that and
of course allowing 3d false' was was so
sad jataka I mean II five I thought okay
i can play five and it's good yeah but I
thought rook e1 first is better but just
happened to get this this is the typical
benoni steamroller especially with with
the bishop exchanged and this night on
h7 I mean black cannot play that in that
way and I thought okay first this and
after this I can I can play this anyway
but i forgot about Queen D for which he
played and now the worst is over I just
missed this chance to to break through
it here yeah I
my original intention was to play this
but yeah I didn't like that and I can
repeat here so my idea was why not play
this first cover d4 and then play 93 but
he can just take okay he played this
yeah I know I tried this breakthrough
and I didn't really understand why he
wasn't playing g5 I mean g5 looks quite
okay for black it's it's it's closing
the the King side and capturing I didn't
really understand maybe there's some
technical way to justify it but after
that i'm just winning here I mean how
will you defend your king of this this
is also coming and this is really dead
from black free no way Jack defenders I
think this was was good enough yeah plus
4 by the comp this is enough yeah the
Benoni sss a demanding opening if you
look at this yeah I really have a hard
time to understand what is going on in
this position what I what I'm pretty
sure of that black young that this was
what's nonsense I mean it loses a bunch
loses much time and just allows me to to
advance my Center I should do something
else maybe capture and I don't know but
but not that I mean this is just just
helping me enormously alright thanks for
watching